you know what it's interesting CU a lot
of abusive women blame the abuse on the
men when really a lot of times um they
were protecting themselves and I found
this out actually when I started doing
shows um my default was always just to
believe people you know what I mean like
when someone gives you a story of
something traumatic that they went
through your your gut reaction isn't to
say I don't believe you or ask them all
these questions but one day a girl was
talking and someone in the comment said
ask her if she file the police report
and the answer was no and I said okay
tell me specifically what happened and
you know the more the story unraveled
The more she said everything um you know
one one girl told
me that her ex pushed her like down or
like shoved her on the ground something
like that and it turns out that she was
trespassing this woman wouldn't leave
this man's house and then was mad that
he kicked her out I mean how else was he
supposed to get you to leave